hello everyone Thanks for attending this
talk today I will talk about fractional
certificates for boundary functions this
is a joint work with shahalo vet okay
let's get started so there in this talk
I will scan three parts first I will
introduce the I will recall the
complexity measures of movable valued
functions then I will then I will talk
about boundary functions in specific
will focus on diffraction of certificate
complexity in fractional block
sensitivity for boundary functions
okay let's get started with the of the
uh from the first part so complexity
measures of Boolean functions
okay so the area of a minimum function
analysis has been uh widely broadly
started in past 30 years one of the
major uh one of the most important
question here is that for any Boolean
functions how could we measure uh how
could we quantify its complexity
so uh in the past uh in in the last
years many uh definitions or many
Notions were introduced from different
motivation different applications
scenarios this Notions includes include
uh this unitary complexity polynomial
degree sensitivity proxitivity
certificate complexity and more so all
of these things all these Notions were
introduced to measure the complexity of
golden functions
okay so as we mentioned before one of
one of the important notion in this
today's talk is the certificate
complexity so let me first record the
definition of certificate complexity for
modern value functions so given any
function s
so for every input X the certificate is
complexity of x
is the minimum size of set I such that
for any other input y whenever Y and X
are identical on I then f x is equal to
y
so this is the certificate complexity
for a specific X
so then the certificate of complexity of
the whole function f is simply defined
by maximum C of X where X is chosen from
the whole domain
okay so this is the uh definitions so in
the past 30 years people made a lot of
efforts to understand and connect the
relationships between these different
measures
so finally
we people we finished the the whole uh
we finished uh all of this connections
and we know that all of these Notions
are polynomially related
so uh for example so we can show there
exists the universal customer C such
that for any wooden value the function f
is degree is upper bounded by
sensitivity to the C so extra and so
yeah
so uh okay so this is the status of the
wooden valid functions then how about
the boundary functions okay so let me
first introduce uh Define the boundary
functions a function at is a bandit if
for every x f x is between 0 and 1. so
recall that in a Boolean value case we
require that f x is equal to either zero
or what for all input but now we only
require it to be uh between zero and
what so this is the initialization of a
Boolean value functions
okay so why should we care about the
boundary functions so first this initial
generalization of wooden value functions
the second
only functions can also be used to
capture content queries even for in the
complicated application of content
computings the Boolean value function is
no longer strong enough to capture
Quantum queries instead of boundary
functions are good so this is another
important motivation for us to study
boundary functions
okay so uh
and how could we quantify the complexity
complexity of boundary functions
okay so in the whenever the case we have
so many Notions to capture the
complexity so in a boundary function
value for the boundary case we can we
can also look for simple nature
generalization for example we can Define
this uh decision tree complexity so
given any F boundary function f f we say
that a digital 3 T Epsilon approximate F
if for a random input X
the absolute value of f x minus TX is
upper bounded by Epsilon okay so uh in
our definition here is the approximation
is in the sense of iot non approximation
or say average case approximation we do
not require that for every x f x minus
TX is up abounded by Epsilon so we only
care about the average case of course if
for if we for if we Define the
point-wise the proximation there could
also be some interesting problems there
but in here we folks we are interested
we are focusing on uh for random input X
okay
so uh there's a uh regard to the
um Notions uh measurements between
different uh Notions okay so we can also
ask similar questions here in the
boundary case actually there is a very
interesting contraction asked by
AutoZone and I and binus so for any
optional pyramid episode
this is a tree
T of depths and polynomial D and one by
Epsilon that Epson approximates f okay
this is a generalization of the Boolean
value case so basically this question is
asking what's the relationship between
degree polynomial degree and the
decision complexity in the boundary case
okay so as we mentioned this statement
is true for Boolean valid case
and okay so the r refline minus is
asking for the boundary case actually
there are there is also a strong
motivation from content Computing for
this uh uh aerosome bindings conjecture
so it captures what is the power of
content queries
okay
okay so then let's move to our top our
uh uh the the notion that we're
interested in so in this talk we are
interested in a notion called fractional
certificate complexity okay so our as I
mentioned our motivation was for the
Arizona's conjunction so but this
conjecture asking connections between
residentiality complexity and the
polynomial degree now why should we talk
about fractional certificate certificate
complexity or certificate complexity
okay so let me tell you the reason is
that okay let me first recall in the
Boolean value of the case how could we
prove the polynomial degree and the
decision complexity their polynomial
related so this the proof is is using
the following framework so we first show
that this decision tree complexity is
upper bounded by the square of
certificate complexity and then I wish
it up about it by a box sensitivity to
the force you finally we shall so this
is upper bounded by degree degree to the
eight so this how should we finish the
proof makes the connection between these
three complexity and the degree
so that we use we always use a
certificate complexity or block
sensitivity as a bridge so as far as I
know I don't know any proof even for the
golden key put invited the case is that
I don't know any proof make making
connections between the decision tree
complexity and a degree without using
neither certificate complexity no block
sensitivity okay so this is what
happened in the Boolean valid case okay
so then the net the okay if we want to
study a conjecture I mean in the bank
the case the first step the first idea
was always to ask whether we can
generalize the Boolean case put it very
case to group The Boundary decays right
so this is the first idea
okay so then we can also try to
generalize the notion of acidification
complexity to the boundary function okay
so of course we we usually have power
and nature generalization here is that
the absolute certificate complexity
so for the absolute certificate
complexity of f as a equal to X is
defined as the minimum set size of a set
I such that for every y whenever y i and
y and I are identical on I then f x
minus f y the absolute value is about F2
okay so we no longer require that
whenever y i is equal to x i then f x is
equal to F1 we only require there are
very close
okay so this is a general uh this is
intuitive generalization of the
certificate complexity form whatever it
takes
okay so but of unfortunately so
this definition seems not a really good
one let me give you this example let's
have we have uh be a function defined as
follows for any input X1 up to uh
exterior objects in so we just Define
the output to be summation of x i is
divided by n then of course this is a
degree one bounding function
however if you would like to study the
certificate complexity of f we can
choose X to be zero zero zero zero zero
and we just choose Epsilon to be 0.01 so
then we can show the certificate of F at
X is Omega n
meaning if you choose any set of I of
size little o n then what happened is
that we can find that y y such that y y
I own zeros but for all of the non-is
parts we we fix all of them to be one so
then we find the Y such that Y and X are
identical on I but f x is equal to 0 and
f y is very close to one so there is a
big separation so
he is still now it tells us the
certificate complexity of f is
Omega n
so now we see a big separation between
certificate complexity and polynomial
degree for boundary function so
therefore this upsell certificate
complexity since not a good one
okay so then that's the motivation one
of the motivation for starting the
fractional certificate complexity so the
question is that what should be a
correct
corresponding notion of certificate
complexity in the bounded case
so now our proposal was the fractional
certificate complexity actually so uh
now let me first Define this absolute
fractional certificate complexity so
everything fractional certificate
complexity of F at a place
is the minimum K such that there exists
the distribution pi over n such that for
every y whatever Y and X are very close
uh under this distribution pi then it
implies if x minus f y is upon it by S2
so this is the generalization of this
absolute fraction absolute certificate
complexity the generalization is that we
no longer require I to be a set instead
we allow it to be a distribution pi
okay let me give you a quick llama to
show to demonstrate how it is the
generalization of the certificate
complexity okay so we have this simple
Lemma instead for every knife and the
Vari input X the fractional certificate
complexity is upper bounded by the
certificate complexity
so the reason is the following that I I
that IAP any set such that whenever Y
and X are identical I then you press f x
minus f f y is
so then we can given this set we can
Define pi to be the just simply to be
the uniform Distribution on I and we
choose K to be the set I the size of a
set I so now we have
done it for every y such that for a
random X for a random I probability y i
is not equal to x i is upon it by one
take one divided by K then it implies Y
and X are identical are I and it also
implies the f x is the f x minus f y sub
upon so therefore we can easily
translate a certificate set into a
certificate distribution so therefore
the the fractional significant
complexity is a simple generalization of
this uh compact of the uh certificate
complexity
okay
so
now we can also uh that Define the
description of fractional certificate
complexity of f is to is to be the uh
the maximum of expression or certificate
of uh FC f0fx so we just
choose the maximum X where X is
distribution from the whole domain so
this is a simple generalization of the
uh is a corresponding generalization of
the Buddha value of the case
okay
okay so then what is the our main result
in this paper so in this paper we
studied the connections between the
fractional certificate complexity and
polynomial
so our main result is the following that
F be any boundary function
of degree D polynomial therefore every
Epsilon
then we have fractional certificate
complexity of f f so f i f c f so f is
upper bounded by
uh linear of detail 8 times log n 16.
look log n to a 16 divided by ABS into
the 4. so we have okay so
in fact in the in the case of uh
abundance conjecture we can always
assume that D is larger than log n so
the reason is that whenever D is much
smaller than log n we can first apply a
hyperconductivity in quality to
approximate the original F by just
um
uh and then reduce the coordinates
okay so anyway so we can always assume
that the example if I put it up and so
therefore
this theorem tells us in this region uh
the fractional certificate complexity is
upper bounded by
polynomial in D and one divided by
Epsilon
so let's compare it to the fractional
certificate complexity on the other hand
for the I'm sorry let's come let's
record the certificate complexity case
in that case we have that there is this
a degree one polynomial which has
uh certificate complexity Omega
so there are huge this is a huge
separation but on the other hand for the
fresh certificate complexity we know
they are polynomial boundaries
so now our proposed is that the
fractional certificate complexity might
be a correct
uh corresponding of the significantly
complexity in a Boolean valid case so
yeah then the question is that could
whether we can use the fractional
instead of complexity as a bridge you
make the connections between degree and
polynomial uh a degree polynomial degree
and a decision complexity
okay so our proof here uh we use some
idea around uh
duality of linear programming so I
probably have I do not have you know
enough time to explain our proof but it
is uh online so it's welcome to uh
please uh so
please read our paper if you're
interested
okay so the last part in this talk is
the fractional block sensitivity
okay so uh as we mentioned so uh in a in
a in a Buddha case in the booting value
case if we would like to make
connections between
uh digital entry complexity and
polynomial degree so we
in at least in my knowledge all of the
proofs have either used the ID notion of
block sensitivity or certificate of
complexity as a bridge okay so then this
block sensitivity is also uh
a similar uh is is also a similar notion
here so let me first then let's talk
about the fraction of oxygen okay so
let's so let me first introduce the
Epsilon System block resistive blocks so
the definition is the following that F
the Abundant function so the family of
sensitive blocks is just defined by all
of the block a set of coordinates
such that whenever if if we fill it off
the bits on B then we changed the
outcome of this function if x by at
least absolute
okay so this is also a generalization of
the generalization of the
sensitivity sensitive Block in a Boolean
valid case
okay
so now what is the fractional
proxitivity
so given any uh
the given any boundary function acts and
any input X we denote the uh we Define
the fractional block sensitivity as the
maximum value k
such that there is this the distribution
new uh over the block sensitivity such
that for every I
then the probability such that I is in B
is up abundantly by 1 divided by K
so actually so this is the the
fractional proximativity is the
generalization of the proxitivity in the
building value of the case
so in a similar as the fractional
proxitivity we have also generalize any
uh block uh sensitivity block uh block
sensitivity into the uh I mean I mean
block sensitivity in a bullet case into
the fraction approxensitivity in the
boundary case
in fact we always have the block
sensitivity is a low band of fractional
blocks
okay
and the similar we can also Define the
Epsilon fraction of approxensitivity of
I it's just the maximum uh I've had
fractional fluxivity of f x where X is
chosen from all of the domain
okay in fact
so
in fact in the fractional case that is
also an interesting very interesting
thing is the fraction of block
sensitivity is actually equal to
fractional
certificate complexity so this proof is
just a followed by a linear duality of
linear program
okay so as we mentioned that uh the in
the Boolean value case whenever we want
to make a connection between a degree
and this energy we always have to use
something either a fractional block
sensitivity uh either so either block
sensitivity of certificate complexity
and in the boundary case and in
fractional case we show that they are
actually the same so the question is so
now an interesting question is that for
if we want to solve the Ada conjecture
Amazon balance conjecture could we use
some ideas around fractional processity
of fractional certificate complexity
actually so uh in in this paper we also
showed another result about sensitivity
about uh sensitivity blocks so we show
that whenever uh if is a low degree
polynomial and has a large balance
and then we can always uh therefore and
and a large fraction of X we can always
find the small set BX
such that whenever if we flip the code
if we just flip a few number of bits of
X well we can flip the outcome of
efforts by at least Omega absor so
meaning for and and significant fraction
of X we can find a significa we can find
a small sensitive blocks
so this is for uh for area for a
significant friend of X we can find it
okay so this all today thanks very much